scott disick is keeping busy as ex
courtney kardashian ties the knot with
travis barker
[Music]
these are just a few of the stunning
photos coming out of italy as both
families document the ceremony in
portofino meanwhile scott is getting out
of town the reality star takes to his
instagram story sharing a photo looking
out of an airplane window he writes
quote where to
playing coy about his destination scott
follows this up with another pick
revealing his flight is just over four
hours this means he's probably not on
his way to courtney's european ceremony
am i invited for the wedding that's up
to them i don't know but scott did offer
one detail to his fans he writes on the
pick quote next stop the beach
this follows scott hitting the town on
thursday
check out scott out and about in west
hollywood with rod stewart and the music
icons family including his daughter
kimberly stewart an eyewitness tells e.t
quote scott seemed to be in a good mood
this comes as scott shares his feelings
about kravis on the kardashians
congratulations brother thank you thank
you congratulations thank you i've seen
you well i haven't seen you both while
he's been friendly with a couple scott
made courtney aware that he's also been
struggling he said this is not the
easiest for me and i just
at the end of the day i want you to be
happy and you know congrats on the
engagement that's nice
this echoes what courtney's sister chloe
told et in 2019
at the end of the day this family has a
long history of co-parenting
successfully and with scott and courtney
sharing three children mason penelope
and rayne family seems to be what
matters to them most my mom and my dad
were like that it took them years but my
dad would come over once a week for
family dinners and would play golf with
my stepdad and so we come from a family
where we believe in that and you share
children with people and that's how it
should be
now back to the italian ceremony
courtney shares these pics showing off
her cathedral veil after the couple says
their ideas she writes on instagram
quote happily ever after leading up to
the event travis's daughter alabama
shares this selfie with her new stepmom
post ceremony kylie is taking point on
social media post
[Music]
the beauty mogul shares pics of their
italian cuisine and kylie captured this
moment of her and kindle as they attempt
to climb this countryside
these staircase are crazy but
kardashians and jenners alike were all
smiles for courtney's big day
[Music]